معبد هندوسي على انقاض مسجد تعتزم الهند
افتتاحه مطلع العام المقبل تنفيذا لوعد
انقطاعه رئيس الوزراء نارين درامودي قبل
عشر سنوات
معبد راما جانما هو ميماندر قصته ليست
عاديه اذ يشكل احد ابرز مظاهر اضطهاد
المسلمين في هذا البلد هذه اللقطات تعود
الى عام
1992 عندما هدمت مجموعه من المتطرفين
الهندوسي مسجد بابوري التحفه الاثريه التي
يعود تاريخها الى عام
1528 دمر بحجه انه مبني على هيكل لمعبد
هندوسي دخل المسلمون في معركه قضائيه في
محاوله لانصافهم في قضيه المسجد لكن
المحكمه العليا بالهند بددت اعمالهم
وانتصرت للهندوس واقرت عام 2019 بمنح
الهندوسيه ارض مسجد بابري نهائيه وقبل هذا
الحكم بست سنوات اطلق مودي وعدن انتخابيا
ببناء معبد فوق انقاض هذا المسجد واليوم
يضع السياسيون في حزب بهارتي جانهه
اللمسات الاخيره لافتتاحه زين المعبد من
الداخل بسبائك ذهبيه واعمال فنيه وبلغت
تكاليف بنائه 180 مليون دولار امريكي ومن
المتوقع ان يزوره نحو 100 الف هندوسيا كل
يوم على ان يبقى الزائر عشرين ثانيه فقط
ونظرا الى حساسيه مكان المعبد لدى اليمين
الهندسي يقول محللون ان افتتاحه سيعزز
مكانه حزب مودي قبل انتخابات
2004 في مدينه ايوديا وعموم ولايه اوتار
براديش ذات الاهميه الانتخابيه
[موسيقى]
اما مسلم الهند سيخشون تصعيدا اكبر يمس
مساجدهم في ظل حكومه مودي التي تمتلك
حظوظا كبيره للفوز بالانتخابات القادمه
فبعد مسجد بابوري تعرضت كثير من المساجد
للاعتداءات اخرها هدم مسجد شاهي في مدينه
الله ابد والذي يعود تاريخ بنائه الى
القرن السادس عشر